[Music]
my next guest co-stars in the new Comedy
Central series Key & Peele
here's a scene where he plays President
Obama's anger translator let's take a
look we've created three million new
jobs
three million new jobs the end of the
war in Iraq in the war y'all we serve as
a reminder that I'm on your side are
coming from the right place coming from
Hawaii okay
[Applause]
Teagan
hey thanks so much for being my pleasure
graduates your show is very funny
that clip has been has gone viral yeah
it's all over the internet so a lot of
people have seen and already I loved it
and when I first saw that I thought
first of all the performances are
fantastic it's such a great idea that
President Obama would have an anger
translator where did you guys get that
idea from watching every single time
President Obama's been on television
ever I mean it's just that the sense of
people will the real that really it came
from that one time when he was speaking
and that congressman screamed out you
you are you are and we were just like
kick him strangle him you know like say
so that I remember he just went he just
well and just that was the whole thing
right and Jordan and I are just like
good at come on let him do something and
and and so we were like Jordan said we
have to figure out a way to have him you
know defend himself they're really
raucous way but we know he's never gonna
do it like it's it didn't feel right to
write a sec he hired somebody
yes express his rage he hired a dude
named Luther who's from the south side
of Chicago and whose Paris is from
Detroit and so you know at Christmas
time you just get knives whatever you
say I'm gonna say whatever you want me
to say you know give a backstory all
this yeah
well on the show there's I saw you guys
do a sketch that I really loved where
you you play to friends yeah who visit
and you have your wives and you tell
each other you're trying to convince
each other that you call your wives
[ __ ] right right but it's quite clear
that you don't exactly right actually
why don't we just show this clip and
then we'll talk about it okay when I
track my wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping out the damn shower
talking about can I help you see that's
crazy right there great I look this
woman I said
[ __ ] you told me 6:45 oh you said that
yes it late about what you say a [ __ ]
though hmm
yeah love it I just love that you keep
going to more and more secret locations
around did that come from real life
that came from a reality television show
we were talking about a scene that we
could do that we would be equal between
the two of us and and writing scenes
like that and Jordan said you know what
I watched The Bachelorette and on The
Bachelorette there were these two dudes
that were talking to each other and then
the one guy was talking other guy about
an another guy another guy who was
nowhere in the room and he said I'll
tell you what man it's just Clark you
know this guy Clark he's just sitting up
in my business and he's trying to tell
me how I should run my date and I was
just like take your crabs clearly did
not say he did not say that - that guy
was so petrified was petrified of Clark
whoever Clark was so we decided to
transfer it to two wives and there's
nothing more dangerous I'm planet earth
than a black wife so it's pretty much
it's like tsunamis are number two and
then black wives